booker gets past o'neal floats it up
around it out
rebounded by utah 15 seconds to go jazz
down three
mitchell takes the three and hits it
ties it at 102
with 10 seconds to go what a shot
donovan mitchell 36 points
needing a three pushing the basketball
willing to roll the dice knocks down the
long ball what they're gonna do four
seconds to go
two seconds to go booker with one lets
it fly
no good and we're going to overtime be
more aggressive
get to your spots and win the battle on
your terms
as opposed to settling
can't hit the three at the horn we go to
overtime
two players in foul trouble heading into
this extra session as the suns win the
tip and booger gets a layup
you see the jump ball bear tries to tap
it back and taps it through
booker trying to get free got held up on
the baseline
cam johnson wide open
and look at the recognition the back
screen pointing to the open guy
recognizing that cam johnson is the guy
over
mitchell into the lane oh what a pass by
donovan mitchell to rudy gobert just
when it looks like mitchell maybe is out
of control
nearing three minutes to go in overtime
booker being defended by mitchell booker
now with 30 points looking for 32 got it
devin booker gives the sons the five
point lead again
you see the screen and roll
[Applause]
booker able to get it now boy go bear
was open there
mitchell turns back spins against paul
puts up the shot
kisses at home off the window 38 for
mitchell
now mitchell charged with defending
booker who's got 32 points
shot clock at eight booker driving pulls
up
scores booker with 34. the lead back to
five for the suns
sun's lead by five plenty of time though
for the potent utah jazz and they cut it
to three just like that as they let
conley go right to the rim
for the easy layup booker leaning in
and kicks it back out to paul the shot
clock at three here's paul four three
good
chris paul with another huge shot when
it matters most
and the sun's lead by six chris paul
not afraid of the bright lights they
brought him here for a reason not just
the lead
[Music]
under a minute to go in overtime
mitchell
turns on the jets gets to the rim he's
got 40 points
utah within four jazz has one timeout
left phoenix with two
conley back door gets the easy layup
great call out of the timeout it's a
two-point game
look at this chris's secret stuff from
from space jam here and
apparently whatever that is it works
you got a guess i need i need some of
that
i mean but he does have it and he's been
doing this his entire life
he has embraced the opportunity to come
to phoenix
and be a guy that puts them in position
to have the type of year that they've
had